hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts exercise targeting
neural plasticity in Parkinson
Parkinson's disease presented by Giselle
in passenger MD associate professor and
clinical scholar in neurology and
movement disorders we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning I'm julissa merav labrys and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offer is free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
for obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce dr. Giselle Messinger dr.
pet singer is an associate professor in
clinical scholar in neurology and
movement disorders at the University of
Southern California Tech School of
Medicine in the Department of Neurology
she completed her MD degree at
University of Southern California her
neurology residency at Yale University
event her fellowship in movement
disorders at Columbia University her
research primarily focuses on
elucidating the underlying molecular
mechanisms by which different forms of
exercise target and facilitate repair of
cognitive and motor circuity through
processes collectively termed here
plasticity her research involves both
animal models of PD and clinical studies
with patients thus providing the
foundation for a translational research
program spinning the spectrum from bench
to bedside she has been funded by
National Parkinson foundation NIH and US
Army and has published extensively in
the field of PD and exercise and repair
dr. pecks and Gert is also committed to
promoting education of wellness and
lifestyle practices to facilitate
disease prevention and to improve the
quality of life for individuals of all
ages towards the school she has
participated in developing as well as
teaching educational health and wellness
programs at universities both within the
United States and abroad please join me
in welcoming dr. Giselle Messinger I
will now turn the presentation over to
her as we try to understand what just
start off with a traditional slide and
this slide is pointing out that it does
represent a so loss pattern that we see
in the substantia [ __ ] the consequence
is don't we depletion and clinical
presentations of Parkinson's then is
characterized by slowness resting tremor
posture instability and stiffness but
what I wanted to do was purposes of this
talk is considered to think about
Parkinson's disease in a slightly
different matter and that is a matter of
circuitry itself so the idea here is
that behaviors really are the product of
circuits and so while don't need
certainly important
about you talk about it is a behavior
itself that is being manifested by cell
loss doping per se but the consequence
of circuit related changes and so what
I'm showing here in this cartoon and are
really two circuits that we're
particularly interested in when we think
about Parkinson's disease the first one
is what we call the motor of somehow
sensory circuit another term that is
commonly used is called the automatic
circuit and that circuit is something
that is what we call practice meaning
that after a lot of practice from let's
say walking or riding a bike that
circuit is formed and I no longer happen
think that say about either walking or
riding the bike it becomes automatic
called non volitional the other type of
circuit that becomes also important for
motor control and but if a movement per
se is what we call the frontal straddle
circuit and this is the other I'm
demonstrating here is this other circuit
that's coming from the prefrontal cortex
and essentially also interacting if you
go at the basal ganglia and so this
circuit is what we call it top down or
optimizer of movement itself it allows
me to update movement as I'm moving from
point A to point B now the reason I'm
bringing out these particular circuit
think about Parkinson's disease and
don't medication as you can see you'll
be really it's important projections of
dopamine are really important in
modulating these two different circuits
what we know is that importance disease
what seems to be more impact is we need
to don't be depletion in the automatic
circuit so patients will tell you that
they don't feel the movements are is
automatic and they haven't think more
about in general so this is thought to
be if you will tire someone fatiguing
it's hard to constantly be thinking
about movement and so people may have
fatigue or may not to be able to sustain
normal fluid because it's hard to keep
processing and thinking about moving in
space so this is why in Parkinson's not
only do we see again problems with
automaticity which we know as brady
kinesia or slowness but we often see
people even upon diagnosis it's not
unusual to see what we call cognitive
executive one idea is that this may be
happening because of this what we call
this compensatory attempt at the brain
the second reason why early executive
problems may occur in Parkinson's may
also have to do with some again related
circuitry to changes in the basal
ganglia so these are game they changes
can directly affect the prefrontal
cortex as well so the take-home message
is that again harkens disease where we
consider it a nerd - jenna disorder
really at the end of the day is a
circuit based problem by the time we're
seeing it clearly problems with
automaticity often problems with
executive problems certainly as five
years large number of patients have and
so these two two sorts of problems are
sort of interacting together and so on
again the reason we think about this as
we move forward in this talk is the idea
of power plasticity if you will fits
into a
disorder so the way we consider that
that is the idea that what we're talking
about is possessing at the level of
circuitry itself so let's go through
some definitions of plasticity these are
rather broad definitions but one idea
that it's just fundamentally that the
brain finds a way to reorganize itself
if you will by forming new neural
connections like this is happening
synaptically so these are connections
within different brain regions and
they're happening more logically so
we're talking about a changes within
spines themselves so the physical or
morphological connections change as well
as functional changes in spines and
another idea no plasticity is that even
is it the idea of homeostasis that the
brain is always trying to reach some
sort of level homeostatic a change where
there may be an injury to one part of
the circuitry there may be some
convincing strategies in other parts of
the circuitry that may be happening at a
circuit level but probably also at a
state level as well and two other points
to consider as we move forward in this
in this discussion is also the very
important idea that neuroplasticity
really is a fundamental considered a
cynic went on of what we consider
encoding the encoding of new experiences
and learning new behaviors so ultimately
when we're talking about how to think of
our prepare in a disorder where
circuitry is aberrant what we're hoping
for
of course is gaining new behaviors and
encoding this new experience through
exercise and finally and important for
this talk is we sort of borrow these
concepts that have been out there for a
number of years and what we're doing is
we're introducing these concepts in the
context of the damaged injured brain so
now we're going to be talking about
importance disease and when we talk
about damage what we're going to be
really talking about specifically is
circuitry and how exercise encoding new
types of experiences may be able to
drive some level of repair so everyone
knows about the ticket in the brain that
came out in the 90s and the course the
idea that plasticity never really ends
it may be different in the context of
aging it may be different in the context
of an injured state but it's still
present
some people also believe that in the
context of injury there may be actually
what we call a window of opportunity
very similar to what we see during
development that may particularly lend
itself where the brain really lends
itself to to be to be able to adapt and
again to be perhaps more plastic so
again getting back to the idea we're
going to use the term experience to see
which can be borrowed from the solar
term but in this case we're talking
about it is environmental experiences
practices that we can see certainly
children when they learn to exercise and
and gain better balance and Paige we
certainly see that and a high number
leveled sports and athletes and finally
what we're saying now is how we're
moving through this idea towards repair
so again in the context of Parkinson's
we talk about repair of particularly
cognitive motor circuitry that we're
interested in alright so everyone is
very familiar with now right now the
exercise of an example of a number of
different types of exercises that have
been reported a clear benefit at various
levels characteristics of Parkinson's
and clean functional measures also in
sort of the traditional scales that we
use but well recently also obviously as
well so the point is what is the
similarity commonality all these
different types of exercises ops tasks
so what should I be doing and what's
common amongst what everyone's reporting
at the end of the day is all these
different types of exercise have in
common the idea of a goal goal based
learning or skill based learning so it's
providing some level what we call
cognitive channels where patients are
having think about what they're doing
process what they're doing and getting
better at the practice getting better at
their skill or at the I come a perfect
analogy I would use for example is the
Olympic diver the idea that the Olympic
diver when he first is diving he maybe
having some adjustments for example that
he needs to make on his dive but as he
gets better and better
he's getting refined and it's moving it
faster and so this is a type of learning
if you will that we are seeing in these
different types of practices but you
notice - it's very common in the types
of exercises we'll be able to talk about
is two different gait and balance and
the rationale for that is that gate
imbalance really is such a high
functional problem that we see and
that's why we commonly target that
particular so what we see now in this
first video in in the first video what
I'm trying to present here is basically
a patient with a horn yard Stage three
this is sort of a baseline kind of
typical Parkinson's patient who has its
cane to walk and you'll also notice I'm
struggling when he crosses even
different flooring and that's slowing
down once he see some changes in the
terrain
what we see now though in video 2 is
just an example one of many different
types of examples I can show you after
exercise any change of medication and
where this patient has across much
faster and again bigger amplitude
biggest radley figure larger arm swing
and so he's having a more natural to
engage so I think the other thing that's
important to keep in mind here is when
we go through exercises with Parkinson's
patients we're not like dragging people
on a treadmill the idea is we apply a
bigger challenge once a patient is able
to what you would consider be successful
at a type of movement so citizen patient
is showing that he's getting she or he
is getting better at some type of
amplitude movement or gait movement what
we'll do is make it harder and so the
idea again behind exercise is making it
skillful and making it challenging by
making it harder so that the problem
solving and getting better so challenge
practice repetition feedback all the
types of things that be considered
learning
certainly important in Parkinson's
disease so back in 2014 as we were
thinking about some biological questions
that we wanted to ask we started
thinking about coming up with some very
specific hypotheses of what might be
going on along the line of plasticity
what we thought about was again what
role goal-directed normal learning they
play in exercise with the idea being
that that particular idea would lend
itself we'll just have to Genesis it's
back to learning that's the case if
people are in deep learning then what we
did anticipate is mute anticipate seeing
changes for example in synaptogenesis
some changes of neurotransmission and so
that was one of the hypotheses that we
started playing forth and alternatively
what we also dissipate is that there
would be gains that may be coming from
the truth free and this may be again
perhaps more on the grooming exercise
[Music]
blood flow may lead to some peripheral
effects the idea is that these are
synergistic effects one does not
necessarily exist but that these two are
interacting if you will at the level of
the brain to create a run at permissive
environment and to support for
particularly practice and synaptogenesis
so with that in mind that was the
hypothesis that we've been working on
and we decided to go on and and begin to
look at that using animal models we had
been looking at using the MPTV animal
model for some time using rodents the
MPTP is a pro toxin that basically gets
across as a window barrier and becomes a
PP plus it gets taken up by the
transporter
and needs to apoptosis so in the animal
model it's a pretty nice wage for us to
replicate your diffic changes and open
circuitry that were particularly
interested in so it's not Parkinson's
disease but it is a model of dopamine
depletion that allows us to begin to
explore changes in circuitry relevant
for Parkinson's disease with that said
then we decided to take our exercise
paradigm and look at the effects of
exercise not so much in the no
protective realm but rather in the
reparative realm so we've been in mind
we decided to look at exercise not
lesioning was complete and so exercise
paradigms actually begin essentially
following days after MPTV so we're
looking at not an or protective paradigm
also our paradigm involves essentially
the use of a treadmill and we use
basically 28 days we were also
incorporating in the analysis assailing
control so we have our saline control
and we have an mptp exercise group as
well and what you're seeing video 3 is
an example of the treadmill that we've
been using in the NDTV mice and we would
argue that there is definitely some
cognate who needs mice because it's not
obviously natural for them but also
because they're being forced to stay up
at the front of the treadmill so I'll
show you another example the type
another type of exercise that that's
used that we're gonna start like this
particular model the restorative effects
of exercise using a treadmill 28 days so
let's go on to show you what we first
reported back actually back in 2004 so
in this video what you're seeing is
basically two animals one the both
parkinsonian that both MPTP they both
have 40% so lost 60% don't mean loss the
difference is only exercise we call the
couch potato Mouse and we can clearly
see its improvement in motor behavior
good at running and so we certainly saw
that we also saw improvement in road
rock performance with this group and
colleagues in our group Thunder is also
reported on other types of motor
benefits including them the motorbeam
are the beam crossing so we've seen
other types of benefits that translate
after the treadmill effects so apart
from that then once we started looking
at the motor behavior one of the
questions of course it came up
immediately is what effects does
exercise pose on dopamine our
transmissions so again remember don't
mean it is important modulator of
plasticity and we know it's needed for
murder acquisition that's been shown now
by number of different vestigators
domain is inquired to me to send em to
justice level of automatic circuitry so
it's needed to act required motor
functions also being for maintenance if
you block don't mean you're gonna lose
mother function so it was obviously it's
an important thing to look at in terms
of what exercise may be doing so we
picked we decided to look at dopamine
levels we look at domain receptors and
we looked at don't transfer transporter
which is cleared domain from the
exercise of space and I'm gonna show you
right now what we were able to see so
this is a paper back in 2007 Joe on
earth science what you see here on your
left and look at the screen is basically
an HPLC where we do is take out the
whole strand while you're seeing is
after creative exercise or 28 years of
sedentary no exercise essentially the
HPLC data show no difference in total
amount of doping so again clearly
improve the motor behavior but total
levels at least by measures that HPLC is
not explaining this difference what we
decided to do is do something called
voltammetry to look at that scandal
telemetry to look at dopamine release
properties at the level of strain but
what you see in the cartoon there is
essentially a section of the stratum and
across there are numbers where the
domain descoth cyclic voltammetry was
used to measure domain beliefs this work
was done by dr. John Walsh's group math
whose big collaborator with us
and dr. Carnac Akopian so in this
studying what they are able to
demonstrate look at the very bottom
figure as you see comparing and btp
these are both MPTV groups the
difference is that in what they've been
exercising after 28 days and the other
group has been sedentary what's
interesting is across the board
throughout the stratum only the dorsal
lateral straight at we see that there is
a larger amount that building being
released so what I'm trying to show is
that one there isn't a total level of
don't mean that's changing there's only
changes in the amount of dopamine
release the other thing that was quite
interesting about this was we were also
able to demonstrate using a meter side
chemistry the changes in the dopamine
transporters so if you look down again
at the minnesota chemistry work by
Fischer Beth Fischer in the lab
basically what we saw was we saw changes
in the amount of direct transmission
don't be transporter protein levels
using Minnesota chemistry again to your
left is the BTB animal to your right is
exercised animal so routes down
regulating the reason this is of
interest is when we went back so again
you see no cheese don't maybe these and
we see that the clearances floor which
matches it don't be transported what's
interesting about that is that we do use
the don't we transport or not
immediately to into in clinical trials
to get some handle on as a surrogate
rather of domain integrity and all I
want to show you is that when we counted
cells in that lead in the night where we
saw no difference in cell numbers so
changes in dopamine transporter or
prairie irrespective changes in cell
number alright so finally the other
thing we became interested in was
looking into dopamine receptors
themselves what we son and this is using
something called in situ hybridization
this is stratum so this is analysis
transcripts and what was interesting
about this it's just that we saw again
changes at the level of in Australian
weather with the two receptors this was
shaded by Marta lukovitch in the lab
when we saw it also the level of Western
so we became pretty interested in the
effects of t2 we decided to create a
ligand for the u2 and with a machine
Angela naka postdoc in the lab also was
able to use work with our animals and
what you're seeing here is a result of a
pet image in a ceiling animal and mptp
exercise take a message is that we saw
an increase in each of expression weird
exercise so altogether what I would say
is close erragadda showing that there
was some improvement across the board
don't mean our transmission so we were
able to replicate the study just a paper
that came out in a report that basically
showed that we were able to see after
eight weeks of treadmill exercise we saw
the same effect in DeNoble Parton's so
let me just walk you through that so
these are patients it's very small and
here I'm just showing you essentially an
end of for Parkinson's to normal
patients and what we see is essentially
improvement or increase in the beach.you
expression I use an image with a fellow
pride and it's a penny major
superimposed in the MRI just to show you
that we're seeing this effect pretty
good the level of stratum and none of
this effect was seen in the don't
exercise all right so now I'm gonna walk
you through just briefly through some
cartoon some work that was done I want
to show the bottom here some work that
was done by a number of people in the
lab showing changes in glutamate nerve
transmission and essentially we saw
changes both in AMPA receptor expression
of the one where we saw sensor with mvtv
in increasing who I want expression with
exercise we saw a diminution of glory
upon expression
Charlie metro elaborate and organ was a
using am to show us that they also say
it's not changes in glutamate levels
presynaptic lee also news increase
including weight storage before exercise
which was attenuated after
sighs again two points right now Anthony
storage elevated if you will with MPTV
of Dobie depletion and it was normalized
with exercise this is of interest
because definitely in Parkinson's
disease one of the ideas is a level two
stratum there's a hyperexcitability if
you will in in synapses and so this
certainly gets in with the general
theory behind what we think is happening
certainly with MPTV and that exercise it
attenuates that could explain that the
improvement in behavior the final slide
that I'm showing here is that exercise
also seems to attenuate this increased
activity or amplitude that we see using
a spontaneous epsps so again this is
work done by Garnica Colby and John Van
Zeeland and so some other work that we
decided to do was looking again at the
dorsal levels freedom we wanted to see
we can see changes in in actual
morphology if you will so I'm showing it
changes in glutamatergic
neurotransmission changes a dopamine are
transmission
well toy in the lab started to examine
changes in synaptic genesis and what I'm
showing you here is a Golgi stain again
focus at the dorsal and Australia but
particularly this is the area circuitry
and then what we see in Figure B is
essentially a blow-up with the Golgi
Golgi neuron and then on section see
what we see is sailing and mptp and then
an increase you can see exercise
increase spine density so the next
question I want to ask is about blood
flow sorry about whether different types
of exercise matters there was another
question that we're trying to address in
the lab and so the common things that we
think about in terms of types of
exercise one is the aerobic exercise
this is the type of exercise when you're
trying to condition to enhance
circulatory and respiratory efficiency
this is the type of exercise you most
commonly hear about doing aging studies
where the idea is that you're either
riding a bike or you're doing anything
to get your heart rate up
there's a skill base exercise which I
would say is the dominant form of
exercise that you see important sees
which is really focused on challenging
kata balance getting better at movement
and processing information and so dr.
horse rider and dr. weighing our
collaborates with us here at USC
essentially looked at this by
ingeniously by putting together a type
of exercise conviction where by animals
so we're using now slightly different
model called the six hydroxy government
we should wrote it this is a rat model
now in this case we're taking animals
give me six weeks of exercise either
going skills or complex wheel practice
or they're going through a non skill
what we call simple real with spokes all
contains and smooth now what's
interesting about the way they approach
this question was that both of these
feel of these wheels were placed on
motorized rod so they're matched for the
aerobic training the more difference
between them really it's a skill the
question we're going to be decided asked
there's difference in blood flow and the
way they approach this was by using this
compound of c14 I anti read this is a
very valuable way to look at mapping a
blood flow in brain of a wake and
unrestrained animal the way they do this
is they introduce basically the
catherine if you will essentially before
they start exercising and then after the
animal completes their six weeks of
exercise it is attached to a pump and
the tag is sequel i hiring the sacrifice
within 24 hours that brings a new and
essentially they could do a type of very
similar to a functional connectivity
study but in this case blood flow and
what you see now in this figure
comparing against skilled to not skilled
it's basically sections of the brain
where you see video activity where again
marking blood flow the interest and this
particular type of approach is what
they're looking at is what's called a
seating study meaning that if you ask
the question if the PFC you see
prefrontal cortex is activated which is
in the skilled exercise Penniman on
skill
what other areas are lighting and what
we can see serving with a skilled
exercise is many more people connected
areas particularly a relevance to us
obviously motor areas this meant a
sensory area and seeking knew so much
greater degree seeking for strata to
much new degree in non skill so why do
we care the reason we care is that this
is beginning to give it an idea a very
important idea that the brain itself is
not a passive recipient of exercise so
this is very different if you will then
what we think about when we think about
example maybe cardiovascular benefits so
it's not just about what the effects are
that are going to the brain and creating
some sort of generalize what we're
seeing is that there's something appears
to be some level of circuit specificity
that's occurring by bridging with what
I'm doing in this case by virtue of
creating a greater cognitive load I'm
actually having some impact if you will
on circuitry itself so one of the
questions we began to ask them is could
these effects be related so the idea
that you're getting changes in blood
flow
could they be driven if you will by some
underlying metabolic plasticity synaptic
change so again getting back to the idea
these two effects of sin adjusting the
effects of exercise particular that a
goal-directed a great learning but there
are clearly some terrible effects that
are playing brutal here and so certainly
for the peripheral effects I mean
certainly know what other factors could
be a player role obviously the insulin
immune system of course are very
important how is this synergistic
working one idea we had going back to
some other mechanisms that me - brain
health focusing now on people at cerner
showed not just the Parkinson's but even
in normal animals
we've changed that extreme obviously
changes angiogenesis it's been shown
over anybody like black and green ow
recently by weighing in our group but
we're moving on now is whether or not
there could be in terms of synergistic
effect in the role of brain whether
there may be something happening in that
level of then a bullet changes that may
be driving if you will not just enough
to Genesis but also some of these
effects on blood so one factor that we
got interested in that we thought could
be of interest that might be if you will
be activated a similar level so what's
happening at the level of the brain that
may be creating changes is this factor
transcription factor called
hypoxia-inducible factor so this
particular factor is of interest it's
been studied by many different groups
but one of the ideas that we have
essentially borrowed from these other
groups is the idea that exercise if you
will like hypoxia emphasized may provide
a stressor within these cells that may
drive the expression of hif or creating
some relevant whether a stabilization of
hif and leading to some transcriptional
activation now this is of interest
because this particular transcription
factors is upstream among a number of
different mechanisms for Catholics of
interests that can support
synaptogenesis and metabolic homeostasis
that includes aspects of glucose uptake
lactate metabolism and your Genesis and
trophic factors as well as blood flow
itself
so each ayah became a particular
interest to us and we began to look at
that this is good just reviewing
potential roles of href that's been
demonstrated by other groups there's
also some evidence by the KT group in
2011 that a chair is increased with
exercise this was repeated now by a
graduate student lab Matt Holliday is
beginning to look at this essentially
looking at the local arena and what
we're beginning to just begin to tease
apart is a timeline in which they began
to see changes in each aya this figure
is just forgive me the show the idea of
how fast it happens will expressed some
we've seen this expressed within five
days of exercise HR is clearly getting
up regulated
we see some correlation with combining
and hydration so the surrogate marker
people of hypoxia and what's of interest
is also the work again as we're I'm just
showing you some very data this is
basically showing that these other
transcription factors that are regulated
by HF are also up regulating as well the
solute transport a lot yeah Roger nice
even bench F so what I'm trying to put
together that is this idea is we're
thinking about how is brain involved in
this benefit efficiently at the level
circuits is that this is a synergistic
effect exercise is really a spectrum of
all the aspects not just learning some
have more than others but also some
aspects that are beneficial that are in
nature so when we think about exercise
and fitness really thinking about is
again a learning aspect of it that drive
circuitry and learning if you will
encoding a competition problem-solving
but also how its recruiting and actually
maybe modulating some of these
peripheral effects as well so it's a
synergistic effect that the brain plays
so in conclusion I just want to
emphasize again simple points be paid
first of all exercise we know
behaviorally you know improvements motor
recently stolen Network studies going on
but clearly compelling data that
exercise also appears to be helping card
and circuitry particularly prefrontal
executive we're showing you an animal
model clearly exercise seems to be
facilitating building or transmission
and importantly in doing so probably
attenuate some of this looking there a
hyper bloom in terms of tribe that we
can to proceed Parkinson's disease that
seems to be attenuated by exercise that
demonstrated that your changes in
spontaneous PSC changes storage and
freedom reducing as we hope to see that
there were there's differences in the
type of exercise you do meaning that
skill based or by climbing loading your
what you're doing with exercise it's
going to change what you're doing to
activate circuitry and we believe that
change driving some aspect of metabolic
metabolism metabolic stress drives blood
bone changes and so this specific
metabolic demand may be what underlies
exercise obviously trying to understand
how this is happening itself could lead
to some very interesting mechanisms that
may allow us with exercise to modulate
some of these benefits so I just want to
thank you for your time this afternoon I
have a wonderful group of people that I
lucky to work with certainly a team of
people that I get to work Michael G
jacket who's a COPI on all the cities I
talked about Fischer started some work
with us of market Lukovic didn't have
any kids to talk about the AMPA
receptors matt holliday some of the
newer ideas Pollock changes will Troy
spine changes John Campea wouldn't leave
a lot of the additional work on the AMPA
receptors and now I have a large group
of people that are helping us translate
a lot of this now into the human works
that we have a number of different human
studies going on that's trying to show
evidence for changes in functional
connectivity using these different types
of X and social and at some time I hope
to be able to come back and talk about
that work as well so thank you so very
much for your time
and that's me learning how to surf and
my other partner in crime John Walsh
who's an expert so thank you so much
thank you doctor pet singer for that
very informative presentation it's now
time for QA if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. pip pet singer please do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for if you are unable to get your
question to dr. petsecure we will follow
up with you via email after the
presentation let's get started
our first question is dr. pet singer
could you give examples of skilled
exercise and how do you think this
compares to cognitive training trying to
tennis plane so learning to serve better
learning to backstroke better so you're
challenging yourself to get better the
particular motor skills so that those
are examples so it's not any particular
exercise there's many different types of
exercise we're you're getting better at
it and challenging yourself you're gonna
get you're gonna gain a skill
even biking has some level of faster if
we look at the literature there's there
has been some studies that have tried to
compare skilled brother exercise versus
cognate training alone and some of that
work has been done for example by it by
our trainer the idea is that probably
skilled exercise does has a bigger
effect if you will on cognition than
simply cognate training so the idea of a
pencil and paper type of cross a puzzle
I think one of the one of the ideas
there is it doesn't have as much
generalizability and the idea say do
crossword puzzles great across the
puzzles but it doesn't generalize as
much as what you get practice motor
skill a physical skill would be point A
to point B one of the ideas there is
that simply because you use so much
different types of sensory input visual
spatial sensory feedback
problem-solving that equates so many
more circuitry if you will we were
practicing a skill that you're going to
gain a bigger job that's just an idea
but that may be what's accounting for
differences so the take-home message is
that exercise to please skilled exercise
will have a bigger effect than just
cognate training person next question
great thank you so much for that answer
the next question is do you see evidence
of synaptogenesis in other brain regions
besides the basal ganglia for example in
the yes we're also looking at some areas
of the brain that we anticipate to be
much of a change with the exercise so
we're trying to look at some control
great thank you so the next question is
are the changes you observe with hif
expression circuit specific or global
diet expression circuit specific or
global anticipate would be specific
there are people looked at hif and show
that HOF effects seem to be happening at
a surface level so it's not something
that you typically see global so we
anticipate that we should be determined
but
great thank you very much for that
answer so the next question is how long
did the beneficial effects of exercise
persist even after you stopped
exercising what I can see is there have
been groups that looked at that question
in context of trophic factors exercise
tremendous show that North America does
go down over time but what's interesting
about some rookies published showed you
sure that there seems to be some sort of
molecular memory to some of these to
this effect like more interpret factors
is that when the animal even though
nurture if in fact it goes down over
time when the animal goes back to to
exercise that say later weeks later the
no-trump in fact it goes up much faster
and so there is this a nice summary data
from animals suggest that in fact it
does seem to be some form of what we
call molecular memory whereby these
these sort of biological facts have some
level I mean that may be upgraded
littlewolf faster over time but apart
from that we ourselves have not looked
at at long term effects yet this is a
that needs to be addressed
thank you another question
okay thank you
looks like we have time for just one
more question and that question is what
role do you think aerobic exercise plays
in your own plasticity thank you for
that question I think also important
because in the very compelling data that
changes in activity changes in metric so
we do think obviously that they're good
some and and again the idea that some of
that may be because of some of these
peripheral effects that the blood flow
may play either again at the new system
or the trophic factors so I'm not
certainly not saying that a robic
exercise doesn't play a role I think the
thing that we're trying to understand is
that there probably are other elements
to exercise particularly as we said
getting back to the idea of learning and
what role that plays particularly in
driving some of these circuit specific
effects so again as we as I pointed out
host on her pointed out those animals
will match the robic but clearly there
was differences it's simply based on
skill so I think the effects of aerobic
again it's working synergistically if
you will with some of these where we
consider kind of skill or learning based
effects interesting to determine is how
much to do short bursts of aerobic and
that's associated getting the system
trying and then you're good to go to get
in some learning so contribution may be
a smaller component of what the person
needs to be doing good when we're
talking about a pair of circuitry and
yes maybe that skill maybe bigger
contributor than and not something we're
trying to address right now thank you
very much I would like to once again
thank dr. pets and her for her
presentation do you have any final
comments final comments the thing to
keep in mind is the original part of the
talk
it doesn't end just because you're
getting you know you have a disorder or
that you're aging the idea is that we're
product for environment
you're thinking about what we do to
enhance cognitive skills and getting out
there the barb and novel environments
are all healthy for our brains Polly
when we talk about brain health and
cognitive so get out there and exercise
thank you
great thank you once again doctor pet
singer I would also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through three months from live date you
will receive an email from labrys
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
bye